Can I help you
find something?
Um, yeah.
Do you have this
in a larger size?
Have what?
In what?
Uh, this shirt in--
in a larger size?
Have you checked
under the table?
No.
Good luck.
So?
I-- I just got
down here.
Oh.
Any luck?
Um, no, these--
These are even smaller.
Could you keep
your voice down?
You're scaring
the thinner customers.
Oh, sorry.
Can I help you find
something else?
Maybe some jewelry.
No.
I just need a--
Just, just this
in a size 12.
Like, a UK 12?
Which is a U.S. 8.
Or like a Japanese 12?
Which is an American
toddler 3.
Is that true--
No, no, I just--
Just this in a...
12, a U.S. 12.
I could call the Midwest
for you?
(distant cowbell)
(sighs)
Oh, where is my head?
We have a whole section
for your... situation.
Follow me.
Please don't touch
that anymore.
What?
Where the (bleep) am I?
Amy?
Lena?
Hi!
It's so good to see you.
Okay, so I asked
for a turtleneck,
they brought me here.
That was, like,
three months ago.
What? Wha--
What is a cow
doing here?
Oh, she's shopping.
It's her daughter's
bat mitzvah.
Is that the AIDS quilt?
Mm-hmm,
Mindy Kaling returned it
after she wore it
to the Golden Globes.
Oh, she looked so warm.
Mm-hmm.
(woman)
Ma'am?
Do you wanna try this on?
That is a tarp
for wood.
Yeah.
It's perfect for covering
your pool or...
your problem areas.
Here.
Oh, okay.
It looks good, Amy.
Really?
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I'll--
I'll take it.
Great.
Let's get you to the register
before the storm comes.
Bye.
Twister is a-comin'.
Daisy?!
Thanks.
Why is there a mall pretzel
in the bag?
Oh, we assume that's where
you'd be going next.
That is really offensive.
I can take it out
if you want.
No.
But just for the future,
just, like, know that
that is offensive.
Do you want dipping sauce?
Yeah.